[Music]
pastor mark the question is
are god's people protected through the
seven last plagues i was told it's only
the last three
well if you look for example at the
plagues of egypt the bible says that
that that these are the seven last
plagues
but uh egypt had ten
the first three plagues of egypt
affected the whole land
these are the seven last plagues because
god's people are protected during the
seven last plagues now let me give you
the biblical evidence for that
the biblical evidence for that is psalm
this is the biblical evidence for it
psalm 91
and psalm 91 puts it this way
it it says
he who dwells in the secret place of the
most high shall abide under the shadow
of the almighty i'll say of the lord
he's my refuge in my fortress in my god
and him will i trust a thousand can fall
at your side ten thousand at your right
hand but it will not come near you only
with your eyes shall look and see the
reward of the wicked
he'll send his angels and they'll keep
you and they'll he'll the angels will
give charge over you to keep you in all
your ways
neither shall any plague come nigh
your dwelling so the bible talks about
the pestilence that walks in in darkness
that's a plague the destruction at
noonday that's the sun scorching men
but it says
because you've made the lord my refuge
verse nine no evil shall befall you nor
any plague come near your dwelling so
once human probation closes
we are not pray things of the devil
god is not going to allow the devil to
torment us in the sense of physical
uh
attacks in the la in once probation
closes no plago come nigh our dwelling
will be protected by god during that
seven last plague period certainly be a
difficult time but keep your mind
focused on god as my refuge and strength
the very present help in trouble
therefore will not fear though the earth
be removed and the mountains carried in
the midst of the sea keep your eyes
fixed on this almighty god who will take
you through he'll never leave you he'll
never forsake you he's going to be with
you in the plagues you need not be
overly troubled about physical
persecution during the plagues